hey guys I'm going to talk about a
hypothyroid caution okay it's actually
two things you have to be careful of so
if you have a hyper thyroid condition
you do not want to consume seek help or
any iodine at all why because the
thyroid is already working too hard if
you had more thyroid hormone it's going
to get worse all right so that's step
number one number two make sure you
don't consume any bile salts okay if you
don't know what it is then you're
probably not taking it but even I have a
gallbladder formulated with bile salts
you don't want to take that with a hyper
only a hypo so with a hyper condition
what's going to happen and you take gall
bladder formula or buttocks bile or bio
extract or bile salts what's going to
happen is you're going to convert more
t4 to t3 and increase more thyroid
activity okay a very bad because it's
already working too hard
so you don't want to take that only you
would want to take it in a hypo
situation all right so I just wanted to
point that out
and just to make sure you know that
thanks for watching